I was wondering if anyone in the Biden
Administration was in touch with Baker
either regarding moderation decisions
that predicts called political
censorship or regarding his transparency
efforts recently so it's up to private
companies to make these types of
decisions we were not involved I can say
that we were not involved first we are
in regular touch with these social media
platforms and those engagements
typically happen through members of our
senior staff in terms of actions Alex
that we have taken or we're working to
take I should say from the federal
government we've increased
disinformation research and tracking
within the surgeon general's office
we're flagging problematic posts for
Facebook that spread this information
here's Karin jump here just a couple
days ago saying that oh no we don't have
anything to do with any of this we were
not involved and then there's sake a
year ago saying yes we do flag posts
we're flagging problematic posts they
were doing it they told us they were
doing it and now they're pretending that
they didn't do it